brian is in rochester new york hey brian
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call i
appreciate it sure how can we help
um got myself into a little situation
here so
i got myself into a car lease uh
sometime back in november
of last year i was working from home at
the time so i wasn't going to put a
whole lot of miles on it
just recently got myself into a new
position as of a couple months ago
which is now more of an outside sales
position which requires a lot more
travel
so um basically i have the leased
vehicle i'm putting a lot more miles on
it now than i
had originally anticipated and i'm just
curious as to what your thoughts were as
far as what i should do
at this point um well you
you really got in a stupid mess and then
you made it even worse with adding the
miles to it so
it was never smart and it never it
didn't just get dumb all of a sudden
because of the miles it was dumb to
start with
so we're going to get out of it that's
what we're going to do have you looked
up what the car's worth
uh i have a general idea as to what it's
worth so
it originally was about a forty thousand
dollar vehicle
uh it's probably now worth somewhere
around
thirty four okay look it up on kelly
bluebook kbb.com
on private sale we'll use 34 for our
discussion have you called the
fleece company and asked what the early
buyout is on the fleece
no i have not okay it was originally 40.
i assume you put down nothing let's call
it 37
is the buyout meaning the early payoff
where you pay off the whole freaking car
because you sell it
okay if that's the case you're three
thousand dollars in the hole 37 minus 34
if those numbers turn out to be true
they're probably not going to be too far
off of that but you need to get the real
numbers
and then um so yeah you just
you gotta have that three thousand
dollars and then we've gotta have enough
to get you a uh
uh some kind of car to drive around but
if you're putting a bunch of miles on it
whatever you're driving you're
destroying its value
so you need the least expensive car that
will get the job done which means it
doesn't break down
and uh and it's not some kind of dinky
butt little smart car because you spend
all day in the car and you're gonna be
at the chiropractor's office if you have
that so you need to you need
like a real car not a pretend car
and uh and you know something that that
is gonna be reliable but
you know maybe a ten thousand dollar car
max and even if you borrow the ten
thousand it's better than being thirty
four thousand in debt and running the
smiles up on this lease because you're
gonna get
hammered with the miles you're putting
on it at the end it's
really turned into a bad situation don't
lease cars period
so folks let's talk about that for a
second okay
78 percent of the bmws that leave the
lot this year will be leased
really caught new car dealers
make more money in their pocket
on the transaction when you finance or
lease a car
then they do by far
they make about six times more if you
lease or finance the car
with them than they do if you just walk
up and pay cash for the car
there's not a lot of spread on cars they
don't make a ton of money
the most profitable square footage on
the new car lot is
the finance office the second most
profitable square footage is the shop
it is not the showroom floor the
showroom floor is the gateway drug
it's what gets you hooked and so the
average car dealer will make
1500 to 2500
in their pocket cash on a
twenty five thousand dollar car on the
lease
they make five to seven hundred dollars
less
if it's bank paper or chrysler motor and
it's just straight up
debt and they make two thousand five
hundred dollars
less if you pay cash on a twenty five
hundred dollar
on twenty five thousand dollar car the
reason all people are leasing cars
is because they're selling you that
because they make more money on that
than they do anything else
so please don't let them set the tone
for your finances
and when you drive down the road and see
all these bmws just know it's not real
yeah it's a marauder it's a rental car
it's a rental car
oh and it's not just
beamers it's lexus it's everything yeah
you're getting slayed people